[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
j'ai deux enfants de merveilleux garçon
mais rassurez-vous ce soir je vais pas
vous raconter leur petite aventures ne
partez pas tout de suite
les raisons de cette petite intro pour
vous dire que comme plupart de parents
j'aime bien leur lire une histoire avant
de les mettre au lit il y a une histoire
particulière que je les ai lis la
semaine dernière qui m'a
particulièrement touché et je me suis
dit qu'il fallait que je vous raconte ça
aujourd'hui
c'est histoire qui commence de manière
assez effrayante d'ailleurs passe sur
une planète assez lointaine il n'y a
rien à voir avec notre planète
rassurez-vous
cette planète est en train de souffrir
d'abord il y a eu
l'air qui était qui était polluée et
ensuite il y avait plus en plus
d'événements extrêmes comme le vague de
chaleur
puis il y a eu le sécheresse ici les
inondations par là les animaux
disparaissent bref l'écosystème mettait
en difficulté
il y a aussi les scientifiques sur cette
planète ils ont dit qu'ils en faisant
bien leur travail cet à cause de leur
utilisation de énergie fossile c'est ça
qui rendait leur planète si malade il
faut arrêter de les utiliser tout de
suite sinon si c'est la catastrophique
énergie fossile vous me dites très bonne
question c'est les charbons gaz pétrole
vous avez peut-être entendu
les scientifiques ils ont dit que leur
planète était enveloppées d'une couche
de gaz
cette couche de gaz normalement c'est
une bonne chose il a permis l'apparition
de la vie sur leur planète
ils disaient que c'est comme si leur
planète portait un manteau si on
l'enlevait il faisait moins 18 degrés il
faisait très très froid
alors ce manteau n'apporte pas de
chaleur bien sûr mais en le gardant il
permettait d'avoir une température moyen
de environ 15 degrés de leur planète
c'est qui permettait justement
l'apparition de la vie
alors
puisqu'ils ont commencé à utiliser
ces énergies fossiles de manière assez
abondante
qui émettait certains gaz qui
s'ajoutaient sur ce menton qui rendait
ce menton encore plus en plus lourd qui
rendait leur planète plus en plus malade
entre un nez un réchauffement
cette réchauffement bien sûr c'était pas
nouveau c'est déjà arrivé dans leur
histoire c'est pas la première fois
mais à chaque fois il a fallu de
milliards des années pour un seul degré
de réchauffement
alors cette fois-ci vous savez combien
de temps ça les a pris
en seulement
170 ans leur petite planète a été
réchauffée un peu plus de 1 degrés alors
c'est ce n'était jamais plus avant
c'était les premières fois
bon les scientifiques ils ont dit que si
vous voulez que ça arrête il faut
réinventer votre façon de produire et de
consommer
comme ça vous pouvez diminuer votre
façon de
vos besoins énergétiques ou peut-être
que vous pouvez l'arrêter
mais allons et non pas été écoutés ils
n'ont pas été pris au sérieux ah mais
sinon c'était une histoire assez courte
c'est pas suffisant pour faire dormir
mes enfants non
ils n'ont pas été écoutés et pourquoi
parce que les habitants ne ces planètes
a été très habitués à utiliser ces
énergies
et c'était comme ça depuis bien
longtemps il ne savait pas comment faire
autrement tout ce qu'il portait tout ce
qu'il mangeait la façon se déplacer
tout était largement dépendant à
l'utilisation de ces énergies
ils avaient ils avaient l'habitude
d'avoir envie de commodités où l'accès à
ces énergies était tellement facile et
puis l'utilisation était sans
conséquence
donc oui c'est un peu compliqué quand
les scientifiques disaient que il faut
changer votre mode de vie et c'était pas
très d'accord
et alors il y a de toute façon faire il
faut faire ça pourquoi il y a pas tous
les habitants de ces planètes a senti
que qu'il y avait cette besoins si il
fait chaud un petit peu de temps en
temps c'est pas très grave qui ne veut
pas avoir un peu de soleil en hiver non
puis d'accord ok les inondations les
sécheresses c'est pas très très bien
mais on les on les a déjà eu avant on
sait comment faire face à ce genre de
catastrophe non
de toute façon on a tous les
technologies l'innovation et la
connaissance donc pourquoi cette panique
est distille
il y a eu des offres eux ils ont dit que
d'accord vous ne voulez pas changer
votre mode de vie pour sauver votre
planète
mais faites attention les énergies
fossiles qui vous utilisez si largement
ils ne sont pas disponibles infiniment
tôt ou tard les productions de ces
énergies fossiles surtout les pétroles
va se stabiliser alors il faut faire
quelque chose
mais ils n'ont pas été écoutés non plus
ce n'est que lorsque ils ont commencé à
sentir les effets de ces réchauffements
plus en plus ils étaient convaincus ils
ont c'est vrai qu'il y avait plus en
plus de catastrophes naturelles et à
chaque fois c'était plus intense alors
ils ont dit qu'il faut faire quelque
chose il faut réduire ses émissions il
faut remplacer ces énergies fossiles par
les alternatives
c'était bien mais en fait il y avait un
autre problème qui était encore plus
complexe
sur cette planète il n'y avait pas un
seul pays qui avait un plan pour réduire
ses émissions qui s'ajoutaient mon tout
pas un seul pays
il y avait certains gouvernements ont
commencé à agir à réfléchir ils ont même
fait quelques propositions ils ont dit
que oui il faut faire plus de vélo il
faut rénover vos bâtiments il faut
supprimer vos mails inutiles et surtout
il faut porter l'école roulant les hiver
parce que voilà
mais les citoyens étaient un peu
perplexe ils attendaient plus d'effort
de la part des grands entreprises et
même de leur gouvernement parce que il
voulait bien le faire de vélo mais il y
avait pas beaucoup de pistes
puis c'était bien c'est vrai que c'était
bien des renouveler les bâtiments il
voulait le faire pour économiser un peu
d'énergie mais il y avait pas beaucoup
de gens qui savaient le faire
et donc
c'était un petit peu compliqué
face à ça
il y avait certains groupes de réflexion
eux ils ont dit que ils ont fait ils ont
lancé un appel à l'action en invitant la
citoyen les gouvernements les
entreprises pour justement agir ensemble
pour réfléchir leur programme leur façon
de produire leur façon de
consommer et
justement surtout trouver des moyens
pour alléger les pressions qu'ils
exercent sur ce ressources précieuses à
ce moment-là je fermais les livres je me
suis dit mais quelle idée
quelle imagination cette histoire
pauvre Jean qui aurait pu prédire les
crises climatiques comme ça franchement
à ce moment là Olivier mon fils à côté
il m'a dit mais maman il y avait des
scientifiques qu'ils ont dit au début de
l'espoir tu te souviens pas
ouais
bon quand les groupes de réflexion ils
ont fait l'appel à l'action ils étaient
écoutés enfants
parce que parce que la façon de
fonctionner des gouvernements et quand
ils avaient les plans c'était de manière
très cloisonnée ils avaient une approche
très secteuriale il regardait secteur
par secteur à chaque secteur dans leur
contexte sont en compte les interactions
qui peuvent avoir entre eux et puis vous
savez c'est qu'ils aimaient bien le
gouvernement de cette planète ils
aimaient bien aussi ajouter un prix un
étiquette de prix il voulait calculer
combien cela peut coûter à chaque mesure
qui est proposé comme si s'ils avaient
suffisamment d'argent ils pouvaient agir
tout de suite
c'est qu'il est proposé les groupes de
réflexion et de regarder ces solutions
avec un prisme un peu plus physique un
peu plus concrète pour dire que est-ce
qu'on peut regarder par exemple combien
de bâtiments il faut construire combien
de kilomètres de route à construire
combien de personnes à déplacé et
combien de personnes a formé parce qu'il
faut aussi penser que dans une planète
où il y a moins de ressources
peut-être que on va pas faire la même
métier quoi ils ont proposé de former
les individus les habitants de cette
planète
les habitants de cette planète ont
compris que cela ne va pas être facile
mais ils étaient déterminés ils ne
voulait pas seulement s'adapter
c'est ces changements qui étaient
provoqué par ce réchauffement mais il
vous le définir résilient
pour un avenir ou ces ressources des
biens plus rares
et en serrant le coude
ils ont réussi à faire un changement
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait le première
chose ils ont regardé ils ont réexaminé
leurs besoins énergétiques
ils appelaient ça sobriété
ensuite ils ont dit que pour les mêmes
usages est-ce qu'on peut utiliser un peu
moins d'énergie ça ils appelaient
efficacité et à la fin si il nous reste
encore d'énergie si on a encore besoin
d'énergie pour utiliser il faut choisir
les énergies qui n'aimaient pas autant
d'émissions qui s'ajoutaient sur le
manteau oui les transformations étaient
pas faciles
était un peu long mais régulière
et en fait surtout
ils étaient tellement contents de voir
le changement en face de ils étaient
concentrés plutôt
préserver leur nature et les résultats
financiers et à la fin
ils n'ont pas réussi à retourner en
arrière et réparer tout ce qu'ils ont
causé comme dégâts mais ils ont réussi à
construire un avenir
ou c'était plus possible c'était plus
vivable et ils étaient surtout fiers de
faire partie
de la solution que la problème
l'histoire se termine comme ça je
fermais les livres je regardais mes
enfants en train de dormir rêver
peut-être et je me suis dit que ouf
heureusement qu'on a pas des problèmes
de cette ampleur mais bon si ça nous
arrive un jour je sais quoi faire il ne
faut juste un plan merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]